economía en france 24 me acompaña en el
estudio de daniela blandón daniela buena
noche bienvenida hoy hablaremos entonces
de como ya ha ido a la economía mundial
en seis meses de que llevamos con la
pandemia de ccoo y 19 empezamos entonces
con el crecimiento económico así es
ramón muy buenas noches pues ya de por
si la economía no venía también antes de
que llegara la pandemia según naciones
unidas el producto interno bruto global
registró en 2019 un crecimiento del 23
por ciento este fue el más bajo en una
década raúl el resultado se debió en
gran parte a las prolongadas disputas
comerciales sobre todo entre eeuu y
china pero la llegada del coronavirus
que fue declarado oficialmente pandemia
en marzo origina una recesión mundial no
vista en décadas también un desempleo a
niveles históricos cientos de miles de
empresas en quiebra y años enteros
perdidos en la lucha contra la pobreza
entre otras consecuencias aunque las
consecuencias son distintas para cada
país en particular a manera global se
espera una contracción económica de
entre el 49 por ciento
75 por ciento así lo dicen las
proyecciones del fondo monetario
internacional el banco mundial y la ocde
que es la organización para la
cooperación y el desarrollo económico
por mencionar sólo algunos organismos
así es a nivel de usted tocaba un tema
muy importante y era el desempleo le
pregunto qué ha pasado entonces con el
tema laboral tal vez este ha sido quizá
la consecuencia más visible en los
diferentes países de acuerdo con la
organización internacional del trabajo
en el primer semestre de este año se
perdió en el mundo lo equivalente a 400
millones de empleos de tiempo completo
para la segunda mitad del año hay 13
escenarios de los cuales el neutro dice
que se pueden perder 140 millones de
empleos adicionales las cosas podrían
empeorar si hay una segunda y prolongada
ola de la pandemia de contagios y si
vuelven también las restricciones una de
las conclusiones a las que ha llegado
naciones unidas
es que lo que va de la pandemia los más
afectados han sido los países en
desarrollo
o mejor los países en vías de desarrollo
y en especial las mujeres
daniela uno de los sectores también más
afectados ha sido el turismo y le
pregunto entonces cuáles son las
proyecciones mire para nadie es un
secreto que el turismo es probablemente
el sector más golpeado de toda esta
pandemia raúl a comienzos de la pandemia
casi todo el planeta interrumpió sus
vuelos y apenas se están terminando de
reanudar las operaciones en los
diferentes países las grandes
damnificadas son las aerolíneas que
llevan consigo toda una cadena
productiva como los hoteles etcétera las
pérdidas estimadas para este año superan
los 84 mil millones de dólares sólo para
las aerolíneas varias de las cuales pues
ya se han declarado en quiebra con casi
8 millones de vuelos cancelados sólo
entre enero y julio de este año la
organización mundial del turismo también
tiene tres escenarios para 2020 si la
paralización total se quedan los cuatro
meses iniciales que ya pasamos las
pérdidas serían de 1,2 billones de
dólares
pero si duran total ocho meses subirían
a 22 billones y si se pone más difícil
la situación la estimación más pesimista
es de una pérdida de 33 billones de
dólares- raúl lamentable entonces la
situación para el turismo àngel le
pregunto los indicadores
bueno la bolsa de nueva york cerró en
terreno mixto este viernes con nasdaq
marcando su peor semana desde el pico de
la pandemia en marzo en europa las
principales plazas bursátiles cerraron
dispares con un euro muy fortalecido en
caso particular de londres se benefició
de la recuperación económica en julio y
en américa latina' altibajos en las
bolsas en especial en argentina que bajó
más del 2 por ciento después de haberse
derrumbado el jueves y para finalizar
que nos trae como cifra del día 1 raúl
es la cifra el día pues un solo
candidato que quedó en la carrera por la
presidencia del banco interamericano de
desarrollo que se somete a votación este
sábado en asamblea general de
gobernadores se trata de mauricio claver
carone de origen cubano pero
nacionalidad está
unidense lo que lo convertiría en el
único no latino al frente de la
organización en toda su historia hoy
argentina retiró la candidatura de
gustavo béliz quien era el único
contendor que quedaba en esta carrera ya
la ex presidenta de costa rica también
lo había hecho un grupo de países entre
ellos argentina méxico costa rica y
chile había promovido el aplazamiento de
las elecciones hasta marzo del 2021 por
coronavirus pero tiene el apoyo de
colombia el salvador brasil bolivia y
uruguay entre otros países sin sorpresas
entonces de quién será el nuevo
presidente del banco interamericano de
desarrollo gracias por la información
ustedes también gracias contribuir con
nosotros
i